Too much exercise can KILL YOU!
This is the best news I've heard all week!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - with an interesting
new study about: the SILENT killer.
Now we've been taught to believe that exercise
is great for us - because most of the time,
it is!
But it turns out there's a small portion of
the population who exercises too much - to
the point where it may actually kill them.
Now chances are you've heard stories about
people who are super healthy, run 20 miles
every single day, and then all of a sudden
- boom, they drop dead out of nowhere.
Most of the time, that's caused by cardiac
hypertrophy - which is what happens when you
exercise so much that your heart muscles get
enlarged to the point where they obstruct
your ventricles, until eventually you just
die.
Now most of us don't have to worry about that.
It only kills about 100 people per year in
the US, and almost all of them are insane
athletes.
HOWEVER, a new study out of Germany finds
that high-intensity exercise puts us at risk
for more than just cardiac hypertrophy.
The results, which were published in the journal
Heart, show that people with existing heart
disease who "overdose" on high-intensity exercise
- may actually increase their risk of death
from heart attack or stroke.
Researchers looked at over 1000 people, who
had been diagnosed with stable coronary artery
heart disease for 10 years or more - and found
that those who completed daily, strenuous
exercise - were more than twice as likely
to die from a heart attack or stroke, than
those who exercised moderately.
By contrast, people who didn't exercise at
all, were 4 times more likely to die of a
heart attack or stroke.
Current guidelines say that heart disease
patients should do up to an hour of moderate
activity at least 5 times a week.
Which is still in line with this study, although
their results seem to take on a sort of reverse
J curve - where no exercise is really really
bad, moderate exercise is ideal, and too much
exercise is bad - but still not as bad as
no exercise at all.
It might seem counterintuitive to think that
exercise could possibly harm someone with
heart disease, but other studies have found
similar results.
Endurance training, in particular - has been
shown to send the body into an acute inflammatory
state that, over time, can damage the heart.
Of course, none of this should serve a deterrent
to exercise, unless you're running marathons
every week.
Not exercising at all, still has the worst
possible outcome - but the intensity and duration
of the exercise we do, are things we should
also be considering.
What do you guys think?
Is high-intensity exercise gonna kill us all?
I can't say for sure, but I'll tell you this
much - it definitely won't kill me.
As always, if you have thoughts about this
episode - leave em in the comments below,
and for more videos - subscribe here.